Speaker 1: We have a great subreddit with nearly
35000 of our viewers and listeners subscribed for
free. You can join the discussion at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit that's already.
A few interesting posts I spotted this morning
that I wanted to discuss with you today. One asks
Who can win in 2024? David, sir, if you read this,
I'd like your take despite it being too early.
I just don't see Biden running in 2024. He'll be
in his 80s, and I think the next three years will
affect him far more than past presidents. Harris
may be the presumptive nominee, but she seems like
a weak candidate versus Trump or DeSantis.
So who would be a strong candidate in 2024?
Give five bucks a month to voter registration,
registration and outreach programs today,
folks. Yeah, this is. I mean, listen, that's the
analysis I made about two months ago, and I said,
we're not yet ready to really talk about this
in detail because there are so many unknowns
who will be the Republican nominee. Is Joe Biden
running for reelection? If not, is Kamala Harris
the presumptive nominee? But I've said before,
most who wrote to me about it agreed, although
a few people were kind of upset with me. I see if
it's Trump is the nominee in 2024. I see a photo
of Joe Biden, who will have been attacked for
four years and will be in his 80s at that point as
having a tough time beating Trump a second time.
If it's not Joe Biden and it's Kamala Harris,
I see Kamala Harris, who remains not
particularly popular today, but there's
still a lot of time to go. I see Kamala Harris
having a very tough time against Donald Trump.
And then if it's not Trump and it's right now
based on polling, Ron DeSantis would be the most
prominent name, although it's it's very early,
and this is why it's tough to talk about it.
I see Ron DeSantis as a more competent version
of Trump, who also has a totally plausible chance
of defeating someone like Joe Biden or Kamala
Harris. Being from Florida could help him with
the state of Florida as well. So I share the
concern. I don't have answers. I'm asking all
the same questions as this viewer I'm coming
to so far more or less the same conclusions.
And I don't have the answers, but maybe people
in the audience do. Another post I spotted asks,
Would you support something similar to a
vaccine passport but for antibodies? Seems
like this would be something the left and right
could compromise on, but I don't hear it being
proposed from the left. I'm wondering if there are
arguments against it or if people are even against
it. So I guess the question is if you could
prove you have antibodies to the coronavirus,
should that count as being vaccinated anywhere
that you need to be vaccinated if you have
antibodies and it's it's very complicated. There's
two primary problems, I think. One is antibodies
as measured by typical blood tests measure only
one type of antibody, and it's only one element of
immunity. We still don't know how does that number
relate to your level of protection and ability
to spread versus other types of antibodies and
potential immunity? So that's part one. Part two.
There's less consistency about natural antibodies
and how long they last. We don't know if you're
more sick. Do you develop more antibodies when you
recover? All these types of things are still being
explored. And so while there's still variability
in terms of antibody development with vaccines,
there's more known and it's more uniform and
more consistent than the decay appears to be more
predictable. So I think those are sort of like
the two main issues with saying we should have
an antibody passport just like we do a vaccine
passport. Also, it's significantly more expensive
to test for antibodies, and it also is much more
involved than simply to goat. You get a vaccine.
It's free to the end user who would pay for, you
know, different people have different blood test
coverage through insurance. It starts to get
quite quite complicated. Last thing? This is a
very interesting article that was posted, all of
the discussion of the worker shortage that we've
been seeing. It's important to know that since
March of 2020, the U.S. has issued 1.2 million
fewer visas to work eligible foreigners. So
a lot of the right wingers and by the way,
this report is from the Cato Institute,
not exactly a left wing publication.
One of the reasons right wingers are saying,
Oh, it's Pete Boudette judge's fault. It's Joe
Biden's fault. Joe Biden is the Grinch who stole
Christmas because of supply chain issues and
all this stuff. We already know the supply chain
issues were an issue. In 2020, nobody was blaming
transport. Nation Secretary Elaine Chao, back
then, nobody was really blaming Trump for that,
now they're blaming Biden and Buddha judge. But
the other issue is the U.S. has issued far fewer
work eligible foreigner visas since March of 2020,
partially under the guise of the pandemic. Yes,
that is a big factor because
the U.S. counts on that labor
and it's not being discussed at all. And it should
be that that is something right wingers may not
even know about or maybe glad about, because they
say these people are stealing our jobs, etc. Well,
that's part of why we're having the supply
chain and labor resource issues right now.
Join the discussion at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit.